Now that we know our value of e, or at least many digits of it. Though, not
nearly an infinite number of them. We can see how those numbers we had on our
table, introducing us to the idea of continually compounding interest.
Definitly do approach this value. There we're getting closer and closer to it
as we moved on the list as n got bigger. And in fact, the formula for
calculating continuously compounded interest, does involve E. Here it is. So,
for continuously compounded interest, we have this formula. A equals p times e
to the rt. As before, A stands for the total amount of money in the account,
after t years have passed. P is the principal amount invested in the account.
And r is the annual interest rate. Remember, e is not a variable. It's that
very special number we've just discussed. What if we kept Grant's situation
exactly the same as before. A principal of $20,000 and annual interest rate of
4%, but this time we let the interest compound continuously. How much money
would he have after five years then? Don't forget to use our new equation And
please round to two decimal places.